then there's a strong community of
people that think that Sandy Hook was a
hoax and that this was staged and that
the maybe people in the film were acting
how can you squash that yes I mean the
idea of you know the truth their
movement and denying the tragic shooting
is it's just nonsense
it's nonsense it's of course insulting
and tremendously hurtful to the families
who lost loved ones to the entire
community of Newtown as it would be in
any case where you know whether it's 911
or other shootings where there are you
know conspiracy theories I mean it's
it's nonsense it's not worth certainly
the community's time nor our time but it
is certainly unfortunate that they have
reached out in such personal ways to
families who who lost loved ones it's um
shocking and disturbing to me as a
documentarian I was aware of it and had
to make a decision you know not a
difficult decision not to give that any
lip service whatsoever it's no different
to me than Holocaust deniers and a whole
number of really you know crazy
conspiracy theories but I mean what I
can do is mirror one of my subjects mark
Barden who lost his seven-year-old son
Daniel just recently for the first time
somewhere we encountered somebody who
didn't was not a truther as they call
themselves he but he revealed that his
son was one of those people and revealed
that to mark and I thought mark was just
going to go crazy on him and he just in
the most dignified way said don't I wish
that were true
don't I wish this never happened then
that I had my my my Daniel back you know
what I can say is that there's twenty
eight thousand people in Newtown I'm
pretty sure all of whom were traumatized
in one way or another by this
whoo and the ripple effects throughout
Connecticut of everyone who knew
somebody who went to those funerals and
it's just really it's not even something
I can comment on it's so it's so
disturbing well lastly and then we'll
move on from that why do you think the
the just I mean the vitriolic comments
that are on these videos and it just
knowing that there are families that
have been affected by this people whose
lives will never ever be the same why
why such a strong argument that this
never happened why do you think these
people feel so right to make these
arguments you know I guess it's the
subject of another documentary honestly
I have in my mind thought what what is
that the root of these kinds of
conspiracies are a majority these people
mentally unbalanced do they then get
followers that but I don't think it's
different than Holocaust deniers and any
other number of you know 9/11 conspiracy
theorists it's you know it's do I think
it could be as simple as you know an
article I read the other day that said
perhaps they're just in you know want to
be in such denial that's such a horrific
thing could happen yeah that that this
could could actually happen I mean
another small just detail thing is from
what I understand a lot of the parents
fought hard to keep certain crime-scene
photos out of public domain which I'm
very happy that they won that fight in
Connecticut so that they wouldn't have
to if they didn't want to see those
images out on the Internet and so I
think that you know for those kind of
people may have fed some of this that
they couldn't access you know maybe the
same kind of evidence if you will you
know and the same thing happen with
Osama bin Laden I mean it's happened
with so many things of why show us the
proof so anyway I it's not something I
like to spend a lot of time thinking
about because it's just so
awful